how did this particular research
research project get started this
particular research started after
various other studies looking into the
effects of psilocybin on the brain and
NST on the brain and this was the work
of robin kaha Harris who his interest
came out of his own psychoanalytic
studies and his also work as a
neuroscientist and he was very
interested in how we can explore the
unconscious mind so much of our behavior
is controlled by the unconscious mind
and yeah it's very difficult to study
scientifically and psychoanalysis is
very it's almost seen as more of an art
than a science
so he wanted to find ways in of looking
at the brain the unconscious mind and he
he started studying psychedelics with
David nuts the david nuts is a quite
well-known professor in this country for
his activism in legalizing drugs he was
at he worked with the government and he
was the drug czar and he informed them
how to advise them about the scientific
harms of different drugs and how they
should be scheduled or you know where
they should be in the schedule of
illegal drugs and he was sacked very
famously because he his scientific
report stated that MDMA was less
dangerous and horse-riding okay so he
was sacked for that and he has gone on
to be a real innovator in drugs policy
and drugs research just recognizing that
lots of the drugs that are illegal might
hold potential for healing yeah whereas
alcohol and cigarettes that are legal
really don't so it's time for a more
free thinking approach so it was David
and Robin together that started this
research and it was very difficult for
them because there's so much red tape
around this because since it was made
legal in seven early 70s it's been very
hard to get a license for the home
office to do this research but once they
once said work gone through the process
yeah it became easier for them to then
do another study in another study so
they've really been on a roll they did
sometimes
is looking at the effects of psilocybin
and honesty on the brain and then they
realize that they the findings that they
had indicated to them that it was time
to start looking at set aside with a
clinical population and the key finding
was that psilocybin seems to deactivate
the part of your mind or brain that is
responsible for ruminating hmm for
negative thinking on a loop so they
realize that for people with depression
this could be really really powerful so
they this the study that I have was
involved in was a clinical study looking
at 20 people with treatment resistant
depression mhm and it was the first
study of its kind in the UK and there
have been some studies in the u.s.
looking at psilocybin with people with
depression and anxiety secondary to a
diagnosis of a terminal illness okay so
are these the studies that were
happening in the 60s and 70s are there
more recent recent work so in the 60s
and 70s the work well in the 50s 60s and
70s there were hundreds and thousands of
studies yeah and the findings were
really very positive and it was all at
great and then it was became illegal and
then the research just dropped away but
then it started again in the early 2000s
I think maybe 2006 around that time and
maybe slightly higher than that and some
of the people that had been involved in
psychedelic research in the 60s started
to say are we really you know we really
need these tools they were really
working we need to get them back again I
think so bill Richards who's a
psychologist had been working one of the
clinics in the USA the Marriott married
and Psychiatric Center had this had this
clinic there there are some good YouTube
videos showing people having LSD
sessions you can see the kind of
psychiatrist sitting there with her with
a woman who is on her LSD and they yeah
they basically realized that it was time
to go again so they kind of galvanized
their team got a new group together
and started started up again and this
was just like these drugs had existed at
the University and they just had a store
of them or they lobbied to to make this
happen
how did it go how did they actually get
this appearance so I think that there
were there are various companies now
that a mate that is synthesizing
synthesizing psilocybin yeah and they
can provide it to researchers with a
license to use the schedule one drugs so
but in order to use them in a study you
usually need it to be GMP grade which
means it's kind of very pure and able to
be used it's gone through lots of
testing yeah so there are very few
providers of GMP psilocybin so it takes
a lot of a lot of the difficulty of
doing this research isn't just the
bureaucracy cutting through the red tape
getting the licenses the lack of funding
because the government's office
obviously don't want to fund this and
but it's also actually getting the
psilocybin and getting enough of it and
getting it that's stable and intestines
yeah and so what clued you into the fact
that I was working with depression and
versus you know some other trait that it
might affect well I think it will be
helpful for so many different mental
health difficulties but with depression
it's this the ruminating quality of
depression the fixation on certain ideas
and concerns so psilocybin and
psychedelics seem to be very good when
when people are stuck in a very fixed
pattern of thinking or of living
psychedelics can break that pattern they
can provide this state of when you look
at the the images of brain communication
pathways they go from this kind of mmm
kind of segmented lines to this full-on
explosion where things that parts of the
brain that don't talk to each other will
talk to each other and suddenly there's
this flexibility so I'm curious about
what the experience is for the following
days but I think Before we jump in we
should talk about like what one of these
sessions actually looks like yes in the
last study there was a low-dose
a high decision the low dose session was
10 milligrams and the high dose was 25
and they look pretty differently
sessions so a low dose session so
firstly the setting is that people would
come into the clinic and they will have
to had some sessions with their guides
beforehand so everybody has two guides
their clinical clinicians therapists and
they get to know the participant quite
well we have some sessions where you
just share about their lives and hear
their story and you tell a bit about
yourself and it's quite a nice human
equal relationship very respectful and
quite different to some doctor-patient
kind of have you done both like both
type of relationships yes okay yeah yeah
very different yeah so I suppose if I
was working the NHS as a therapist with
lots of patients and there you're so
busy you have you know seven people
coming up every day and there is this
huge there's this huge need and they're
often you don't really have the tools to
help people because often talking
therapy doesn't really work especially
if you can only offer people six
sessions mm-hmm so you you you aware
that people have this need in that
they're they're so they're so desperate
and in crisis and there's not much you
can do so in a way what that happens is
you put your barriers down you put your
boundaries down it's like this is what I
can do this is what I can't do and you
you keep yourself you keep yourself a
bit separates and what happens to those
people they have to go private so well I
I guess these are usually people that
really wouldn't have the money to go
privately so they just they come for
their sessions and you give them what
you can but you can only give them six
sessions so there's this sense of a bit
not being enough yeah and it's hard for
them and it's hard for you and it's hard
for everybody there and then they will
often get antidepressants because that's
something that the doctor can easily
prescribe and it feels like it's doing
something but then often that doesn't
work either
okay um antidepressants prescribed at
the same rate that they are in the u.s.
here in UK they prescribed
incredibly frequently so I think last
year was our record number of
antidepressant prescriptions there was
sixty four point seven million
prescriptions in the
okay fancy depressants last year how
many people live in the UK I don't know
but it's I mean it's it's a lot more
people than you would imagine is it
yes it's huge huge ISA fence depressants
it isn't really talked about very much
and you know as a short-term thing to
get people who are crisis time I think
sometimes it can be really helpful and
for some people it works but for a lot
of people it's a short-term fix it
doesn't really change the causes of the
depression okay doesn't really there's a
root cause something's not right and
it's not it's not addressing that okay
so in in these like psilocybin sessions
yeah you you more you're just like
having a conversation like you would
between friends before you get going so
someone gets comfortable with you say
you you you feel really comfortable so
yeah you are you are you're more you're
going through something together if
you're on a journey together you know
and you've been through all the
different things that can happen and how
to manage the session and so it's sort
of like a QA as well so I show up and
I'm like okay like here we go yeah ask
you so yeah so you would have a couple
of sessions beforehand to get to know
each other okay and then you would tell
me about your life story and the
difficult things that had happened and
the things that you were scared would
come up because they often do so all the
things you don't want to talk about
might well come up so all the taboos you
talk about sex and death and you know
all the things that people hide in there
yeah cause it's and then when that's all
been openly talked about then you're
ready to go and they come into the
clinic they have the capsules on the
loader session it's just two capsules
and then they sit there with their two
guides in a room that's full of nice
decoration so it's in a hospital but it
doesn't look like a hospital room and
they have a playlist of really beautiful
music it's been specially designed for
this experience and then they sit there
through the day and on a 10 milligram
dose you would see tend to see more
psychodynamic stuff so internal
exploration people feeling more
emotional feeling that they maybe get
some insight into different parts of
their life and often this struggle hmm
because the the amount of psilocybin is
there the ego is still intact
there's still a there still an eye there
there is still a you would still be
there knowing who you are just more in
touch with the stuff that's going on
dummy that you don't often think about
so the the stuff that's being pushed
away so in other words you can you can
kind of put a finger on it and you can
identify it but you don't you don't let
go of it or how would you put it so the
difference between a 10 milligram dose
and 25 milligram dose usually is that a
25 milligram dose is so high yeah that
it will complete with it you can't
resist it so with a 10 milligram dose so
okay imagine a bit like this with 10
milligrams imagine you've got this
cellar do you use the word cellar in the
US and in the basement there are all the
skeletons and the monsters and the
things that you have pushed away and
what psilocybin does is it can open the
door of that stuff so that you can
process it so you can go through those
things and be free of them as you go
forward in your life and it's not just
the monsters that are down there there's
also loads of other really amazing
things but but there's it's intense and
it can feel a bit like taking the
psilocybin is a bit like kind of opening
that door and you have to let go and
surrender to whatever is coming up you
have to be there and welcome it with 10
milligrams it opens it a little bit and
so the things come out and you might be
having a conversation with a dead parent
or you might be thinking about a
relationship that ended and it's like a
very intense turbocharged therapy
session but you can fight it you can
kind of put the lid down you decide you
don't want to do it with 25 milligram
yeah you can't fight it you can't say I
don't want to deal with this I've
decided I don't want to it's open
everything comes out and you just have
to surrender and just trust in the
process and your role as a psychologist
but what are you doing throughout you
know in a ten and a 25 milligram session
helping people surrender helping people
face the things that are difficult
helping people sit through the pain of
it and by being encouraging that that's
the right thing to do that they're safe
mm-hmm people sometimes feel that
they're dying because on the ego is
deactive thats quite common because when
your ego is activated you have no sense
of self and sometimes that's a beautiful
experience
mean what when I talk about that you
know the the basement being opened it
sounds like it's always really difficult
it's often a really beautiful experience
for people or often there'll be a bit of
those yeah but when when you die on a
psychedelic experience when you when you
have an ego death that can either feel
like oh I'm at one with the planet
I am the plants and the trees I am
everything or it can feel like I'm
physically being killed and dying really
so you experience physical pain yeah
okay sometimes and you're just saying to
them you're okay thank you
yo this is exactly what you came here to
do you know this is all this is it's
counterintuitive yeah you know if you
feel that you're going mad great go mad
if you feel like die and go die if
you're exploding let's see what it's
like to explode it's it's about in a way
the whole concept of mindfulness and
meditation is about allowing things in
and just sitting with them rather than
distracting or pushing them away or
trying to always be kind of achieving or
feeling good but never feeling you're
feeling mm-hmm and it's about that it's
about this like turbocharged mindfulness
it's whatever is here let it be here
don't fight it don't push it away don't
try and nullify these negative emotions
do sadness do suffering believe it is
there like is there a certain vocabulary
that you train someone in before they
get going I just wonder if like if
someone is more precise with their
language does that affect the experience
or is it kind of open to anyone
interesting well often the experience
has had this noetic quality which means
that they beyond words you can't put
them into words so I think really
people's kind of it doesn't really
matter if you go beyond that you go to a
different level beyond that often hmm
but we do talk them a little bit we
don't prepare them for any kind of
experience because we don't want to
prime them in any way so we just say you
might have if you feel that you're dying
that that's okay is you're not actually
physically dying will look after you
it's all fine yeah and but we don't
really prepare them because we just
don't know where they're gonna go so we
just the main preparation is just
surrender that's the one word surrender
and both are both other people in the
room psychologists or they they serve
different roles so there's
in our next study that's just about to
start we can have one lead guide and one
assistant guide it's a kind of training
program where people they can get
experience and then they'll also be the
psychiatrist that's not in the room most
of the time but is on-site if we need
him and then yeah so okay and so what
are you taking notes are you just
hanging out what do you do um last time
we would take a book in with us
sometimes because there's a lot of time
when they just got the IP earphones in
the eyeshades on and they're just lying
back on the bed and so that it's just
silence for a long time yeah but this
time I think we're gonna try not to do
that because actually it's just good to
be there fully with them even though
it's it's a long day it's like six hours
that they might be on this absence but
just really just just being with them
and and seeing the subtle changes and
listening to the music and being in the
moment you know that's so great and so
the people that have participated in the
study so far do they have any shared
qualities or traits like what how does
someone end up in this study well say in
the last study people had treatment
resistant depression so it meant they
tried at least two different types of
treatments that hadn't worked yeah so I
would say when I think back at those
twenty people they weren't all
psychedelic entities yes a couple of
them had tried it before but like 20
years ago and actually the one that had
tried it before had had a terrible LSD
experience so he was really put off by
it yeah so the the the expectations
about psychedelics were quite negative
in many ways and there was a lot of
anxiety around them but I guess also
dead maybe people had access to some
media coverage of the positive
possibilities of so Simon so it was a
bit mixed there was some expectation it
might help them but they were scared
about how they were going to get to that
good outcome right well because they've
all opted in but the reason they opted
in I think this is all of them is
because they were absolutely desperate
for something that was going to help
them they had tried everything they'd
had depression for an average of 18
years and they tried between I think 3
and 11 types of antidepressants imagine
trying 11 types of antidepressants and
every time you go and your doctor gives
you a different packet and they have
side-effects and they take weeks to work
mm-hmm and they don't and then they
don't help you 11 types so and they'd
also had like
lots and lots of talking therapy up to
six different courses of talking therapy
so these are people that they would try
anything for some of them it was like
ECT was the next option which is the
electric shock therapy of the brain so
people were like well I'll try this and
then if this doesn't work I'll try ect
because it's either this or I can't
carry on living like this it's like this
or I'm out in his ECT proven to be
effective well it's some very severe
cases there some it might help some
people there's also cognitive problems
there as a result of it can lead to
severe difficulties a memory loss and
it's I mean I think sometimes it works
with people but it's really the last and
so are these before you start taking
some and so you're taking these
antidepressants they're super common way
too common in the ass are their
long-term effects of taking these
medications because I know so many
people are also manipulating their brain
who don't necessarily have depression
you know they're they're taking
nootropics their team's focus drugs or
or whatever it might be
have you found there to be any long-term
effects of suicide they're not so yeah
and they were searched into the effect
of antidepressant drugs often is very
short-term it looks at them for a very
short period of time without much
follow-up yeah so because that serves
the purposes of the people making these
drugs so I don't know of long-term
follow-up research all I know about is
there was experiences of people that
I've spoken to so with my clinical work
as a clinical psychologist seeing people
saying they're just you know they make
me feel worse often people would say
they made them feel worse and often in
terms of the long term I think with
antidepressant if they work well for
people and they keep taking them if they
don't work then they they stop taking
them so we would be interested in the
long-term effects of antidepressants the
people for whom they are effective but I
suppose for those people who and they
are affected they're a complete lifeline
so um yeah I don't know about the
research on that well yeah I don't
understand it to the same degree as you
do is it is it common for someone if
they do find
an antidepressant to be effective yeah
to maintain use forever it is quite
common for people to use it for a long
time yes um so for example one of our
participants had been on antidepressants
even though they haven't really helped
him they helped him a little bit so the
way he described it was like life was
really unbearable and the
antidepressants took off the peaks and
the troughs so the highs of the highs
the lows of the lows so just made the
range a bit more bearable so even though
he still felt very very depressed they
kind of kept him going
he wouldn't say they worked but he took
them anyway because we need and the real
reason and this is the real thing that I
do that gets talked about enough the
real reason I think so often people stay
on the antidepressants is because when
they try and go off them it's awful
so there was this one participant who'd
been on antidepressants even though they
hadn't worked for 20 years and in our
study people have to come off their
antidepressants in order to participate
okay because it really psilocybin is not
nearly as effective as it really takes
the I mean it takes the highs and lows
yeah it stops that word from working
seriously coming off his antidepressants
before the study he was in he was
tearful the whole time people described
electric shocks going off in their brain
and bedwetting sometimes that was
something longer they off these before
they they take so Simon well for some
people you have to withdraw them for
quite a while yeah so you know you can't
go into a psilocybin session with
someone so turbulent so that was a shock
for us one of the big shock findings was
oh my goodness me withdrawing Francie
depressants for these people was
absolute hell often and so I think
that's why some people could stay on
them because coming off is too difficult
yeah
but then a lot of people so we can talk
about obviously the effects of the
psilocybin but it seems you for most
people lasts for about two or three
months and then the depression started
to come back hmm and I think that's
because for lots of reasons but partly
because we didn't this isn't a
psychedelic therapy so we're not giving
people an integration really we're not
giving people the full package windows
integrations so a psychedelic
intervention has to have three sections
preparation the session itself an
integration preparation is as we've
talked about getting used to how it's
going to be getting to know each other
the
building the trust the session itself is
about surrender being there together and
then the integration is about the
participant themselves weaving a
narrative about what on earth they have
just seen and gone through they may have
had mystical spiritual experiences they
may have had experiences of dying of
amazing insights into their life it's a
weird wonderful world okay and they need
to piece it together in a way that makes
sense to them so that when they in the
months and years that follow they know
what that experience means and it helps
them live their life because there's no
use in having this incredible opening if
you then go back to your same old life
right so what psychedelics do is they
give you this window of opportunity so
okay so like if you imagine like so this
is one of my colleagues analogy I'm
spinning from him if you imagine like a
snowy mountain and then and you go
sledding and you go sledding down the
same track and you always go so we're
there there's a track in the snow it
gets deeper and deeper and deeper mhm
when anytime you get on that mountain
you're going into the same track because
it's just the groove is getting deeper
and deeper if you imagine that as your
mind in depression you'll go through the
same thoughts ruminating about the same
things worthlessness whatever it is
whatever your ruminations are just
sticking in that rigid pattern people
describe it's like a mental prison
they're stuck in the same old patterns
and then with psilocybin or psychedelics
it's like you've got this this mountain
with it's like deep deep ridges that you
always get at and then with psilocybin
it's like a snowplow that just comes
across and wipes everything through so
in this state of brain connectedness or
the entropic brain or the integrated
rate of however you want to talk about
it it's this it kind of wipes it clean
not that it doesn't like wipe your brain
clean their senses it takes everything
out of it but it just provides this
opportunity of flexibility and then you
can kind of sledge anywhere you want to
go so after a psychedelic experience
people have this window feeling really
often really fantastic for a number of
weeks or even months and this
flexibility I can I can try this I can
try this try new things and so if in
that window of opportunity they start
new habits they change their
relationships they
make those life changes then we think
that it can really last longer the
effect can last longer but if you just
give someone a psychedelic and you don't
encourage them to make the most of
window of opportunity then what we found
with our participants is that the
depression came back after three months
or so mmm I mean it makes sense right
your life is already structured in such
a way it's not like your memory is wiped
clean so you kind of fall into your
habits as you would absolutely
interesting okay so let's go into the
actual effects right so well water I
mean let's be specific
right so without sharing anyone's name
like what have some things yeah what's
happened what's happened so of our 20
well the first thing to say is that they
all said that they would prefer it to
any other treatment they tried three of
them didn't have a real effect from it
hmm but they still even though it hadn't
really worked for them they still felt
that the whole something about the
process was very different to normal you
know it's different from getting a pack
of pills it's you're sitting there
you're talking to people you're getting
to know them they're listening to your
life story it's very human and all of
these people had had therapy before yeah
okay so you perceive it is different to
talking therapy yeah yeah this
difference in the relationship it's not
the the therapist sitting there and kind
of trying to help but not really having
time to help it's like there's something
different about the way you you go into
it together it's a there's a there's a
bond you develop the bond even if it
wasn't effective for then there's
something powerful about that
therapeutic bond because it's quite
different to how we how we do things in
this in our culture it's yeah this is a
philosophy yeah I mean I've heard it
frequently mentioned in the context of
couples like having these like
experiences where they you know they
take mushrooms or whatever it might be
and for whatever reason they can like
work through something or like people
work together to put together all these
things and it's not the same thing as
like let's have a coffee yeah exactly
there's something and there's something
about the bravery of your going through
this unknown thing together there's
something inherently bonding about that
so so yes so for three people it didn't
work they didn't have a psychedelic
experience in that they didn't really
see anything even
there on the hide the same dose as
everyone else and we've got some ideas
about where that might be and but we
need more assertive to really work it
out so three of them it didn't work then
for six of them
at the six-month follow-up they were
still depression free hmm so for six of
them it really really it wasn't you know
life-changing incredible yeah yeah
amazing thing and then with we've stayed
in touch with people now so that we know
that actually of those those six people
for most of them the depression did
start to come back at some point around
the year point but that some of them
have had their own follow-up treatments
okay so they have managed to keep
themselves well through finding because
if you've tried something that works and
you want to try and find a way of
accessing it again so they found places
in the world where you can legally have
it again okay so but they need someone
with them for the second third well so
let me tell you about the other one
Aaron and then I'll go two days so six
of them there was still well after six
months three of them it didn't work and
then four eleven of them and this is yes
the majority of them they were really
well for three months
depression free or very mild symptoms of
depression but then after three months
the Depression started to come back
again and didn't go quite back to how
they would have been before for most of
them but they the depression came back
so what's been really hard for us is to
have these people so seventeen after
twenty and these are people that nothing
has worked for for years and years and
years 17 out of 20 people come and have
these experiences and it's just a day
you know it's not even that it
complicated you they take some capsules
and they sit there for a day with you
and they feel better for months and
months and months and they are their
partners say they have a sparkle in
their eye that they've haven't had for
decades they're starting new hobbies
they're playing with their children more
it's a beautiful to see and then the
depression starts to come back and then
you have to save them I'm really sorry
but we can't give you another session
because we're a research study with no
funding or you know we all work for free
all the time we all you know cut corners
in every way we can because we don't
there is no money here that our team is
we based on the funding of one
incredibly generous donor mm-hm
and apart from that we don't have
funding really
we're so financially constrained that we
the budget that we do have we need to
use on forward the brainless research
forward right so we have an obligation
to people with depression everywhere to
to get this treatment available for them
so our next study we're going to be
looking at and psilocybin versus
antidepressants we're going to be
comparing them and that's an important
thing to do but we're spending all of
our budget that we have on that study
which means that we just cannot give
sessions to the previous people because
if we did we wouldn't be able to do the
next study right so we have to say to
them we said to them from the beginning
we can't give you follow up doses we we
have to keep forward in our research we
can't so it's incredibly difficult and
ethically hard to open people's eyes to
something that works when one person
said it was like turning on the lights
in a dark house and then it's like the
lights fade again but they they still
say that you know now they've tried
something that worked they have the hope
that they can access it again and some
some of them have been able to access it
again man yeah I mean it it totally
makes sense it's like anything it's like
exercise right if you if I were to go on
a run every three months and that would
be all I needed to stay in shape though
yeah amazing so it's incredibly
effective yeah but it also makes sense
that you have to keep at it yeah and so
are they are these swapping it out for
you know like people talk about going on
these like ayahuasca retreats and you
know you list the other comparables so
the only legal way of of having this
experience is there's there's a couple
of places where mushrooms are legal and
then retreats but they're very far away
in the other side of the world and there
are places in Europe where you can have
ayahuasca ceremonies and then there's
South America so it's very difficult and
you require it units for people with not
any major yeah yeah so a couple of our
participants were able to access those
and but the rest of them have not been
able to okay so Center is it common for
them to get back onto the
antidepressants or what are they trying
to do a lot of them have stayed off the
antidepressants really yeah but some of
them have gone back on just because they
say oh I just you know I need something
to help me get through you know it's
just life it's just really tough cuz you
know things happen and someone's farm
flooded and there's this kind of life
happens and people when they're
suffering from depression they just they
need something and that's the only thing
that's available at the moment so could
you walk me through because I haven't
been to therapy of any kind for me I
probably should but walk me through like
the how the conversation might flow
because I just kind of would like some
context yeah so the conversation in the
actual session yeah yeah okay so on a
high dose second it would be quite you
would expect so it's different every
time so you just really don't know but
it would be quite common I guess to have
the participant is lying there and I'm
sitting there and sometimes holding
their hand if they're going through
something painful sometimes not so
sometimes just sitting there and for a
lot of the time it's silence and in in
their world they're battling things
crying and and what you see is very
little that they're just lying there um
so it's very internalised often but then
sometimes they might say oh this you
know i don't want to go there i'm not i
can't they're kind of struggling with
something and so you're just helping
them to kind of face whatever is there
mmm-hmm and then sometimes people are
having a kind of rebirth experience they
you're a bit more like a midwife in a
therapist okay you know it's there's
kind of noises and sounds and you're
reassuring but you're not really in an
intellectual conversation because
getting into the mind is we want to get
out of the mind and right at the heart
and into the body same right so as soon
as you start and what is that what does
it look like what is it it should then
you're you're back in the mind and yeah
brilliant thing about psychedelics is
that they turn off that kind of ego
frontal parts and you can go into the
body and into the heart and so you've
had to totally retrain yourself that's
completely against everything you
studied I imagine a and so are you
asking different kinds of questions or
is it is it just encouragement
honestly it's love it's just love it
really is it's out that sounds really
like ridiculous but it when you boil it
down that's what it is so it's presence
its presence in its love and to me
they're kind of the same
and when you're there in the same way as
when you're well I think actually my own
like experience of having a baby and
looking after a small child who just
happened along side it so I was doing
guiding in my maternity leave so I had a
like three-month-old baby at home and I
was going you know and for the first
time when I first started doing this yak
and now she's nearly three and so I
think my parenting work or my mothering
is actually probably something that
helps me the most and understanding what
the the presence that is needed doesn't
mean that it can't be men as well men
and women both you know can bring that
kind of I guess it's a kind of like
unconditional well the humanistic
psychologists used to talk about
unconditional positive regard which is a
kind of a broad approach of just
whatever you do I accept you and but
it's kind of one step further because
when you're seeing people going through
this kind of pain you do feel a sense of
like love in a different way it's just
human it's not like falling in love with
patients it's like a human compassion
and feeling of shared humanity together
and a feeling of you're just so you're
just so with them and it's like and
they're vulnerable they're vulnerable so
they're like they they you know there's
there's just something special about
that kind of therapeutic relationship
it's very different
yeah and so as someone who's been on the
other side of Thayer like traditional
what what is your experience how does it
contrast well so I did some research
into this and I interview people like
from the study and I asked them to
compare it to the previous survey they'd
had and it was it was in a way I thought
it did really surprise me because I've
been doing this like CBT you know it's
kind of like behavior cognitive
behavioral therapy for years and as my
that was my practice and and I thought
it had been kind of helpful ish I mean I
always knew that it wasn't really that
helpful and people weren't always
getting better but it was kind of
helpful but what people in our study
said was that once it had the psilocybin
and that experience what it was like to
have something that was kind of a
kind of relationship they look back on
the talking therapy that had and just
felt that it was quite and I think
they'd had bad experiences it's not
always like this I know I mean I have
colleagues that have brilliant therapist
and I know that they're there their
clients wouldn't feel this way but
sometimes it can be really directive
mmm-hmm so it's like I've studied all
this I know what the theory is I know
what the model is this links to this
links to this and we have all these
diagrams that we learn when you're
trying to be clinical psychologists of
like eating disorder OCD depression and
you have all these arrows this happens
here here here so you've got like the
like they kind of you know you've got
the system in your head yes like you are
infj yeah this is where you do I've got
to get used to here and there's quite a
lot of pressure on you to get them there
and and you you do this thing called
Socratic questioning which is this
technique where you kind of know what
the answer is but you need to make the
person feel that they get into the
answer says oh but I wonder what what
would happen it but it's directive
because you're trying to get them
somewhere you think you know the answer
and you're the therapist right and
you're the one that trained and you're
the expert and they're coming to see you
and with psilocybin it's completely
different because the expert is
themselves they are the expert because
what's happening the healing power of
this is something in the unconscious
mind their own unconscious mind is
writing itself there's a homeostatic
principle at play here I'm sure of it so
that whatever things if you think of
your body as a system your body and mind
is a system you're whatever things need
dealing with whatever problems there are
in the system forget our manual of ABCD
whatever is actually going on in this
holistic system the psilocybin helps
just kind of goes there somehow
so the unconscious mind is incredibly
intelligent and knows where which parts
of the system are a bit weak or been
faulty and which need changing so it can
fix the glitches in the system somehow
and this is this kind of brain
connectivity all the parts are talking
to each other so it's like almost this
kind of scanning process of like oK
we've got all the information where
where do we need to go to so what that
means in terms of the relationship is
that there's complete respect for them
because they are the ones that are going
on their own journey you can't go on
there for them yeah so it's not
directive in any way we have no idea
where they're gonna go
I have no so say you were coming for a
session I would have no idea really
about what would be the right thing
whenever I tried to have ideas it when I
first started they were always wrong
because the person's own mind is
infinitely more intelligent than I am
right well I mean they just know
themselves they know exactly you're in a
constant conversation yourself I one
thing I always wondered about therapy
having known a bunch of people that have
gone through it is it that matchmaking
process because I've often you know met
someone who's a therapist something like
I don't know if like you're the right
fit for me yeah is that do you find that
to be a real thing or is that just like
my own resistance to like not wanting to
do it it's a very important point
absolutely for talking therapy
especially if it's long kind of
longer-term talking therapy when you
weren't going weekly for someone for
maybe a year or something or a couple of
years so key that that relationship yeah
all the work is done within that
relationship but with psychedelics the
work is really really done on the inside
so I think the match is important in the
sense that if there was a dislike there
you know we all meet people to summarize
for whatever reason they activate
something in us that makes us think
about someone we don't like or if there
was a dislike and there wasn't trust
that would be a problem so then the
participant and the guide have to trust
each other
really really trust each other but that
you know that's usually it's usually
okay as long as is you kind of and
obviously not all therapists would be
guys it takes a particular kind of
approach not needed to be the expert not
needing to talk about stuff in an
intellectual way being comfortable with
emotions being comfortable with not
knowing being comfortable with being and
loving presence and patience you know
it's not something that it's going to
suit and not all people would be kind of
would really trust the process enough to
be able to go through it some people
might be quite suspicious of their or
just not really feel it was right for
them so it's not right for everybody
okay but for the people through our
screening process the people that we we
had come through and and the therapists
that we had it it was tended to be fine
yeah I think think of one person I think
he wasn't fully trusting and of his guys
before it went through and actually he
had a good outcome but I think
he could have done with a few more
sessions beforehand yeah but usually the
trust is there but beyond that trust I
don't think the coupling that the
matching matters because in session sit
okay say say I've got issues with my
mother it might be that when I go and
have talking therapy I might want to go
and see a woman maybe to work through
those that relationship and I might want
someone kind of my mum's aide and it
might you know maybe maybe not sure
those kind of factors there any matter
in psychedelics because you're going to
be going through your month if you've
got an issue with your mother you're
going to maybe be going through that in
your session perhaps if that's the area
that they're scanning princess decides
is most relevant but you're going to be
doing it yourself you might be face to
face with your mother in the session
yeah but it's not the guides aren't
there to take part in a psychodrama
there the work isn't done with them they
just they're just kind of nice people
helping you be there they're not they're
not so much part of the healing okay
yeah that's a very different process
with talking therapy I always my concern
was that I was just gonna look for
confirmation yes and so I would look for
someone that's so close that it was just
like wouldn't necessarily breakthrough
and that's the other thing great thing
about psychedelics as well actually is
that I think sometimes and actually I
can own this from being an exaustive
psychotherapist in the NHS seeing lots
of people by the time the 8th person
came through the door on a Friday I was
so exhausted I might not remember their
notes you know and I might sit there and
why I would fall back on is just being
nice you know being a nice kind person
like I hear you and I am there for you
but when I talk about the love of a
psychedelic session yeah it's like a
tough love I mean it's the if there's no
nice about it as a guide you're like
you're sometimes pushing them to face
really difficult things and the
psilocybin experience itself is often
extremely confronting yeah so there's no
like platitudes or confirmations like
yeah you're doing great you keep going
no but but then like I mean you you've
seen it right there's there's kind of
this this period where it works and then
it stops working well I mean the
long-term effects are necessarily there
how are you thinking about setting
someone up for success like you have you
have another study coming out
what are you gonna do to get someone on
the right track
there's I mean if someone gave me like a
license to use psilocybin legally and
lose money then I guarantee you I can
set up something that would well we all
you know loads of people work in this
field we all have idea I mean we know
with working on the work of they're the
people that we're doing this decades and
decades ago sure and and there are loads
of different models that we think would
be really useful to mix together like
various psychological models that
actually lend themselves really well for
this and meditation is the key thing
like mixing meditation in this so in a
perfect world I think it would be seen
as something that it's it's a journey
it's a long journey into the deepest
deepest parts of yourself and from that
place you're hoping to find a
self-acceptance itself knowing a
self-love that enable you to radically
transform your relationships with
yourself with other people and the world
around you so that was the theme that
came out of my research looking at the
outcomes was that people felt more
connected to themselves to other people
in the world around them so we I would
look at things that help people and
continue that process so it would start
off with the prep phase it would go into
the sessions and then the integration
would be something that help people
maintain their learning mm-hmm and
maintain a sense of community stay
connected to other people and a sense of
a sense of meaning in the world like
we're not just doing it in vacuum
there's there's there's a writ there's
people have real insights about their
values and about the way the world
should be in the way the world is and
they change their behavior in line with
it so things to help people continue
with that and it's not the therapist
saying because that's the other thing I
would do is in talking therapy before I
would say we need to set some goals what
things are important to you let's set
these goals and the feedback I got from
the participants in our study was that
they didn't like when they had that kind
of thing before they didn't like it
because it was someone's kind of telling
them what kind of goal to have and they
would feel that they would fail at them
and even just made them feel worse and
who knows what the right goal is but
with this psychedelic experience people
can they come up with this strangest
most unpredictable goals because
actually what you thought was right for
someone wasn't
right now but they get this idea that
what I really need to do is a B and C so
it would be supporting people to
maintain those insights and new goals
but the key thing as well it wouldn't be
like a kind of one session then you're
okay forever it would be I think it
would be the long journey would be one
where people might have a psilocybin
experience every six months hmm they
might have appeared where they had like
four six months apart and then they're
okay for like ten years and then they
might come for a top-up but it would be
very individually decided upon that
you'd work out with someone if they
needed another session or not but it's
an it's not it's a life journey you know
it would be something that they would
then for deep self-reflection it through
different life stages so maybe someone
you know in their 30s they would have
three sessions and then feel feel pretty
well in their 30s and 40s and then then
the 60 day retire and things get really
difficult they're having to recalibrate
things and they come back for another
like a delegation and they go back
inside and they so I'd say it's an
ongoing thing so that that like
confidence to make a change is change a
more common thing with verses talking
therapy rather than like is it is
talking therapy more conducive to like
and this is kind of it's not the exact
word but like coping like this is like
you have this certain situation you're
gonna be able to deal with it in such a
way versus psilocybin therapy where
someone might be like I can't do this
anymore I'm gonna become a painter or
something like that is that a difference
it's an interesting one I don't think
it's quite so certain types of talking
therapy and more like it so CBT and
things like that short-term therapies
are more about coping coping strategies
helping people kind of keep going on
situation they're in whereas things like
psychoanalysis are more about deep
internal change like understanding their
unconscious mind and how it's affecting
your behavior and making deep changes
but it takes many many years to get to
that so as I say psychedelics are a bit
more like psychoanalysis and that it's
learning to understanding yourself much
much better we know in a very deep way
and making changes and whereas the
psychoanalysis it might be a bit more
gradual that people might get to know
each other much better over say ten
years of analysis
many many thousands and thousands of
pounds spent on it they might start to
understand themselves better and make
those changes with psychedelics it can
suddenly seem a bit more you know
revolutionary yeah but we do encourage
people after a session not to make any
big changes for a couple of weeks okay
just to let it sit and purple ate and
yeah because people often say I want to
change my job or I want to eat it right
and in our sample of 20 people people
didn't make changes new jobs did things
have been frightened up for a long time
change relationships people did make big
life changes but yeah we do encourage
cautions yeah and so for the people who
don't necessarily have access to you
know traveling to South America or
participating in your session what do
you advise them to do I mean you've
mentioned meditation before we talked
about influencer recording like that
seems pretty important yeah yeah what do
you tell them you can access these
states without psychedelic drugs
psychedelic drugs are just one way of
accessing these dates and breathwork
holotropic breathwork is was developed
by stan grof so after psychedelics were
made illegal hit stan grof had been
working in psilocybin and LSD research
in the states in the same place as Bill
Richard so I mentioned before for four
decades and then when they became
illegal he developed with his wife this
other technique to enable people to get
to the same state yeah so you can do
holotropic breathwork workshops and
we're actually we're doing training for
our new therapists this week and on
Saturday we're all going to be doing
holotropic breathwork workshop together
because it's a legal way of inducing
these experiences meditation like deep
deep meditation practice it might take a
long time to get there but you can
access very very similar states as well
and also yeah in a way that it's it's
easier if psychedelic experience can be
really well it's hard to find and then
it even if you do find it you access it
it's even for the people in our study
order ceremony it's intense and hard and
draining whereas meditation you can
start small and build up and you can fit
it in your day
and I've had a meditation experience
that was fully expansive and I've only
had one ever made it may never have
another one but it was enough to make me
know that there is serious you know you
in the same way that psychedelics they
if they D activate the default mode
Network which is your kind of ego
structure in the brain base of the ego
meditation does that - it quietens down
that's mental control a monkey mind yeah
that's quite in the monkey mind that's
all I would say really doing with
psychedelics and with meditation and
then what about maintaining the change
I'm maintaining the desire to change
with with you mean with meditation or
just you know all the above I'm thinking
of yeah from the perspective cuz like
the reality is that most people
listening or watching whatever like
probably won't go through this process
but they I think almost everyone knows
that feeling yeah I was like I
there's just booked the war of art have
you ever read it before spied by an
author Steven Pressfield and he talks
about resistance and oftentimes the
resistance to like push through to
really go for your creative project or
whatever it might be because so often
people who deep down kind of know the
thing that they want to be working on
but there's a fear or there's a pressure
or they're a million reasons to not do
that thing yeah so yeah I guess I'm just
kind of curious if if you often
recommend like a book or a certain thing
to someone
I think getting connected is the thing I
think that's what um when you when you
when you deactivate the kind of the
thing that keeps you trapped yeah and
you can get down to your real when you
when you turn off the kind of the mind
or the ego however you do that whether
it's meditation or walking you nature
whatever you do you turn that off and
you get down to your I would call it
your soul but your space of who I really
am that little voice inside you that
knows what it really wants to do when
you know what it is that your life is
about or the thing that's gonna make you
feel meaning and feel happy and feel
that you have a purpose that then don't
let go of that for anything but that the
weight of the way to make that happen is
to you
to get connected because it's very easy
to you know we're trapped in our head
and we in our culture in the West were
very very disconnected from each other
and from ourselves most of the time kind
of whatever addictions we've got whether
it's Netflix or you know beer or
whatever we're just kind of like
operating this frenzy kind of amps the
real existence when you turn that all
off and you get down into what you who
you really are you need to honor that so
the theme as I said before about what
psychedelics do is make you more
connected to yourself others and world
around you that is the thing that's
that's kind of my motto anyway of like
connection to myself what's my
connection to myself how am I narsing
myself how am i listening to that voice
how am i prioritizing that voice over
the other chatter of the world
connection to others you difficult to
achieve anything on your own
but finding your tribe finding other
people that you were going to do this
with whatever your dream is find other
people that you're gonna you're going to
do it together and then connects into
the world is really just yeah kind of
thinking about what what it means and
the ethical roots of what you're doing
and the value systems and and and
helping it spread wider and wider so
connectivity I mean the interesting
thing about mushrooms in a forest mhm
you've got all the different trees and
like I think two-thirds of the forest is
underground you can see one-third of it
which is like the trees but two-thirds
of it is underground it's like the roots
that go down and the way trees
communicate with each other is through
mycelium and mycelium is mushroom it's
fungus mm-hm so the whole of the forest
communicates through this layer of
mushroom so I think mushroom is a great
it's a great connector and you can think
about that analogy really if you imagine
like you imagine yourself as a tree okay
and you've got your you've got your
trunk which is your connection to
yourself and if you've got your branches
which is your your kind of your ideas
going out and then you've got your roots
and you've got this layer of mycelium
and you're connected to all these other
people and so to make your tree grow
really strong it's about yeah your your
place in the forest you're not standing
alone that's great I think that's a
great place to stop
well thank you so much for your time
you